[Applause]
good evening thanks for being here
great to be here you know i uh first of
all i want to say i saw this movie i'm
going to say it's like a week and a half
ago they got me the special screening
and
uh i went with a couple of the priests
on our show and we were completely blown
away by this film
it's a tall order i would say playing
johnny cash and
you just become him and you forget that
you're an actor playing johnny cash
which is the biggest
hurdle in a biopic so congratulations
it's really an incredible joke
first of all i know you know you've come
on the show a couple times over the
years and i know that
uh one of the hardest things i know that
you love acting you love inhabiting the
role you love the craft
then you got to go out and talk about
the movie which can probably get a
little boring for you because people ask
you the same questions over and over
again is there anything you're doing
this time around to sort of
keep yourself entertained as you go
through this process
[Music]
my question exactly yeah no i always
i i have um
that was for our finnish audience i
think yeah
yeah no i have uh i just create uh
special languages
that no one understands i don't even
understand it right right you do it
you just you you make up like kind of
words and stuff just to do every now and
then you've actually been doing this on
this press tour is that right
yeah a little bit meme you mean
so you do it's like you're doing it for
yourself right well
me and two other people right right
because no i have a friend
uh michael and we call him mewmew and uh
he actually has a song that we've made
up just
just for him just for a new mukage song
right
and um okay yeah that's very important
okay you did it very well by the way not
a lot of people can do it and who have
you been trying to get to do it i heard
you try to
you went on is it uh was it regis and
yeah regis registered he was a champ
he uh he he did it and um he did it very
well
and the first of the did he know what he
was doing how did this yeah
no we went through the entire song
actually he he knew what he knew who's
up he knows the chorus the bridge
everything
right um i'd love to see read the string
you know you're such a high energy guy
right and you also you can add a little
geek
or jenga with it too very nice which is
nice just a little flavor you don't want
to do me
a good guy i just prefer not to go that
way that's not me that's more regis
i don't do that you did it i'm a strict
mew-mew gaga guy
okay okay well whatever makes you
comfortable this is your show
i don't want to push anything on after
the wendy's thing i don't know if it's
mine anymore it might
it might be gone now yeah now you had to
uh you
not had to this i think this would be a
thrill is present at the country music
awards which
you know i mean you're you're playing uh
johnny cash
in the film and then you're asked to
present at the country music awards how
was that did you enjoy it
um well do you know how many people is
that madison square garden do you know
how many people
are there well you know slightly more
than we have in this room right now
a little bit more two and a half million
people wow
and not really
but yeah that's what it feels like and i
walked i walked out there and i
i just i didn't know what to do and i
saw chris christopherson right away
and he gave me a thumbs up and i was
like well that's good i don't know what
that
i don't know how he knows that it's
gonna be okay but somehow there's
something very calming about chris
christopherson
no it's true i found that throughout my
life whenever i'm in a moment of crisis
i look around and chris christopherson
appears
and gives me a thumbs up
no so that so that was good and uh and
then i had to
you know we're presenting and so we're
we go through a list of names it's on a
teleprompter and uh i was a little
nervous
but i got all of those names right but
reese who i've worked with for like a
year
i got her name wrong i called her wreath
on live
television that's great that's great and
um she kicked me yeah
she can be vicious sometimes yeah
i mean uh she plays your love interest
uh
june carter cash in this film and i want
to talk about the movie now first of all
this great honor you got to meet johnny
cash even before
you made this film before you knew that
you were gonna be making this film is
that right
yeah how did that come about um well i
was invited over to dinner
at his um a friend's house and um
went over and it was an amazing
experience i i can't tell you what
what that's like and the words can't
describe what it was there
john and june were just beautiful people
and they sang this song
um together and looked each other's eyes
and um
and it was this beautiful spiritual and
then i had to leave and
john stopped me as i was walking out and
he was a real fan of this movie i did
gladiator
and um he said i can't do his voice
anymore but
he said my favorite part is
when you said your son squealed like a
girl when they nailed him to the cross
and your wife moaned like a [ __ ] as
they ravaged her again and again and
again i love that part
we all remember that yeah yeah i mean
the most sadistic dialogue ever
committed to celluloid right right and
that's what that's what he like caught
his attention well he's
an artist who went to a dark place many
times in his music so
it was amazing that dichotomy was just
seeing him with june and this
this great love and then that's the
dialogue that he quotes and it's
fascinating you know one of the things
you do in the movie uh in addition to
uh you know playing the music and seeing
it is that you you have in the movie his
deep
baritone and i was just thinking how did
you do
that i mean i you could put a gun in my
head i could never get my
voice lower than like a helium squeak
but you have
i'd be like hi everybody i'm johnny cash
you know but you
i almost got that role in that cost man
i think but you
uh really you you changed your voice and
i'm wondering how do you do that
with uh with vocal lessons and working
with the vocal coach and it's
the most humiliating process i've ever
endured
um because you do these exercises all
these vowels
and you do like the up and down
and it's so uncomfortable i can't tell
you and to transition as i hear this guy
going fungible
up you go how do you go from that to i
shot a man in arena to watch him die
yeah yeah strange it's not getting you
in the mood to sing at johnny cash so
it was very very difficult well we have
a clip here
uh this is a great scene actually this
is uh
in the movie uh johnny cash has gone
through this uh terrible problems with
uh
addiction he's been gone for a while and
then he wants to come back and he wants
to
appease this idea to sing at folsom
prison his record label says that's a
stupid idea
no one wants to see that but he goes
ahead and does it and i think
it's one of the biggest selling records
of all time
this sounds great it seems like an
interesting yeah yeah thank you
thank you very much i like to set up all
the clips myself i just enjoy it
all right thank you uh anyway here's a
little thing i did
uh called walk the line but take a look
at this club
my hat's off to you now cause i
never had to drink this yellow water you
got here
this song
[Music]
[Music]
they
[Music]
you know i think like a lot of people
i'm
i thought i was very familiar with
johnny cash's work and a fan of his i
saw this movie and i went home that
night i stayed on the internet all night
like
getting more johnny cash songs and
trying to look at rare footage this
movie
makes you want to like revisit
everything he did which is really cool
uh
walk the line opens tomorrow uh go see
this movie it's fantastic
a real honor to have you here thanks so
much